we're continuing to speak to people in
the audience you really make the show
what it is if it weren't for you i would
just be a guy in a room with a
microphone talking to nobody so it
you're making this situation much less
sad that you're there
let's talk next to oh i don't know let's
go to mark from dublin now is this
dublin ireland of one or one of the many
dublins in the united states
this is dublin ireland all right well
hello welcome welcome
hi um
so
i was wondering um
what your thoughts
are on the tr on trump's immigration
policy inc compared to obama's
immigration policy i think you and i
would both agree that
whilst trump is a lot worse than
obama and biden
neither are as progressive as we would
like and
i believe that obama deported more
people than any previous president
so
how do you think we can critique
trump's immigration policy
and retaining the big picture of
systemic issues with the american
immigration policy well i think the
systemic issue is that the
the there's a couple of systemic issues
and neither trump nor obama
solved them and we could argue about to
what degree did they make them worse or
do nothing about it or or fix them a
little
one is the overwhelming focus on the
individuals who are
in the united states illegally
versus cracking down on the companies
that continue to hire them cracking down
on the companies that continue to hire
them if you really wanna like aside from
a guest worker program
whether it should be illegal to just
come like whatever your views are
the the lack of crackdown on the
companies doing the hiring continues to
be one of the biggest aggravating
factors in the situation remaining what
it is obama didn't fix that and trump
didn't fix that i think trump showed
even less interest than obama did in
dealing with that so that's one thing i
think that's a fair critique
number two um
you know daca
is a massive issue some kind of
permanent solution to daca
seems to be in the top three issues when
it comes to immigration
and that continues to be an issue and we
can continue to criticize for the lack
of a of a permanent solution there so
i agree with you that president obama
left much to be desired when it when it
comes to immigration
trump really scaled up
one of the most outwardly
despicable aspects which were you know
the family separations and the so-called
kids in cages and i know the counter is
that that also existed under obama i
wouldn't deny that but scaling that up
in conjunction with this very
xenophobically motivated uh uh
i call it for shorthand a majority
muslim country ban i think there's
certainly more criticism of trump than
of obama although there's plenty to
criticize of both
okay fair um what are some specific
policies under trump that you think um
made him particularly bad um just the
scaling up are there additional policies
well so again a lot of what trump did
wrongly on immigration
is
not just the scaling up
of the um separations and kids in cages
it was also using the pandemic to very
cynically be able to do more deportation
under the guise of public health while
clearly not actually caring about it
using the doc the lack of daca
resolution
um as a sort of uh
stick with which to bully people i mean
it he didn't pass that much policy other
than the majority muslim country ban it
was sort of the totality of his rhetoric
his cynical use of the pandemic to
continue a xenophobic immigration policy
you know it's all these things together
it's less about here's the laws he
signed the bills he signed okay
okay okay so it's also how he enforced
the laws that were in place indeed okay
okay um yeah well thanks for taking my
call um appreciate speaking with you
again my pleasure thank you so much for
calling in
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com slash pacman i've
been using privacy for a little over a
year now you've heard me talk about it
before it's a lifesaver and here's how
it works takes just a couple of minutes
to set up anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plug-in let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
pacman